لقد كان أسبوعًا كبيرًا لإعلانات الدردشة gbt
أولاً، فقد نمت العيون
والآذان من خلال ميزات صوتية جديدة تم الإعلان عنها،
لذا ستتمكن قريبًا من الدردشة مع
Chachi BT تمامًا مثل Siri من Apple أو
Alexa من Amazon بالإضافة إلى قدرة
روبوت GPT على الاستجابة للصور
أعلنت الشركة الآن يوم الخميس أن
Chachi BT سيكون أيضًا أكثر تحديثًا
حتى الآن، وقد استخدم روبوت الذكاء الاصطناعي
المعلومات التي تم الحصول عليها من
الإنترنت ولكن حتى سبتمبر 2021 فقط، لم
يكن على علم بأي
شيء حدث منذ ذلك الحين ولكنه
مفتوح الآن للذكاء الاصطناعي.  يقول المشتركون في نماذج الدردشة gbt
plus وEnterprise سيكون لديهم
خيار تصفح الإنترنت باستخدام
محرك بحث Microsoft Bing،
وفي النهاية سيتم توسيع هذا ليشمل جميع
المستخدمين في الإعلان على X openai
قالوا إنهم سيتعلمون بعض الدروس من
جهد سابق قائلين  منذ
الإطلاق الأصلي للتصفح في مايو،
تلقينا تحديثات تعليقات مفيدة
وتتبع ملف robots.txt
وتحديد وكلاء المستخدم حتى تتمكن المواقع من
التحكم في كيفية تفاعل دردشة gbt معهم،
وهي محاولة لتهدئة المخاوف
بشأن دردشة حقوق الطبع والنشر التي لا يمكن لـ GPT إنشاؤها إلا
من مجموعات واسعة من  المعلومات التي
تستهلكها، وبالطبع
ستستهلك الكثير الآن، حيث تستخدم بعض مواقع الويب
بالفعل تعليمات برمجية لمنع روبوتات الذكاء الاصطناعي من
سرقة معلوماتها، بما في ذلك
منافذ الأخبار مثل New York Times
ESPN وCNN، وآنا ستيوارت، وCNN في لندن.